whether you love it hate it or have
never thought about it chances are some
nanny wants to ban it presenting the
nanny of the month runners-up Alabama
lawmakers who want to make it a crime to
annoy someone online thereby outline
most what happens on the interweb and
the American people not you dear viewers
but most of their countrymen who
according to a recent survey claim to
support personal responsibility but also
dig smoking bans trans-fat bans and keep
voting for petty dictators that guard
any of the month New York Mayor Michael
Bloomberg who's ended a long-standing
tradition of private donations to the
city's homeless shelters I challenge you
to go into any neighborhood that is
actually poor representing real New
Yorkers and you try to live for a week
on the sustenance that they they limit
it to the amount of food and let's see
how healthy you're gonna eat Glen
Richter has been bringing bagels and
other types of food to homeless shelters
for two decades but recently Bloomie's
Health Department decided to refuse such
offerings because the city can't assess
their salt fat and fiber content but hey
there's also dumpster diving although
the food in there also hasn't been
approved by Medlin Mike you realize what
it is to be hungry
vegan ape oh by the way cities like
Philadelphia Houston and Phoenix have
also cracked down on volunteers who feed
the homeless check back next month for
more examples of busybodies minded your
own business